joe biden he's the great white hope
[Music]
to keep up with a reset a return to
normal
after the era of donald trump which is
an interesting logic
when you think about it because trump
only took the white house because
not enough americans could bring
themselves to vote democrat
after the normal obama
biden era that normal was what led to
trump in the first place
the writer caitlyn johnston describes
making biden president
now as like using a time machine to
prevent a train wreck
but only going back to one millisecond
before the train wreck
occurred the center right of the
democrat party
basically the corporate democrats only
got their candidate over the line
because
while bernie sanders left-wing socialist
supporters
were no fans of biden they hated trump
even more so what can we expect from the
new boss
well the memes that have been going
viral at least give us some insight into
what
people are thinking like this one
biden's administration will definitely
have a more humanitarian
less orange face it will still probably
drop bombs though biden supported almost
every single
american war for at least three decades
kate if you want to protect yourself get
a double barrel shotgun
at least trump brought some troops home
and only bombed a runway in syria
biden will probably be hoping that the
same old american behavior abroad
sanctions bombs bullying can be covered
up by being
extra progressive at home there are
rumors that he's going to make michelle
flournai
his new defense secretary the first
female defense secretary she's described
as a veteran
pentagon moderate that should really
reassure the people under the bombs
so progress for women a positive agenda
in the lgbtq community
this is the girahood taking a knee in
the culture wars
to cover up the inevitable which is more
of the same
what happens in four years if americans
realize that the only thing that's
changed is how
nicely the government talks just before
it screws them
maybe a return to the old normal